the movie is set around a family of
three curtis samantha and their mute
daughter hannah living in lagrange ohio
curtis works at a mining site and is
saving money for hannah's cochlear
implant surgery everything is going well
for the family until one day curtis sees
massive clouds forming in the sky from
his backyard within only seconds a
tornado manifests and starts approaching
the house when it starts to drizzle
curtis discovers the liquid falling from
the sky is not water but motor oil
before he can react his usually calm dog
turns aggressive and attacks him curtis
suddenly jolts up from his bed realizing
that all that was just a nightmare even
though it was strangely vivid curtis
decides to dismiss it and go on about
his day at breakfast he feels
uncomfortable letting hannah play with
the dog he takes her away and asks his
wife to put the dog outside the house
when he is not home samantha inquires
why but gets no reply as curtis sets off
to work dewort is curtis's work buddy
and a close friend like curtis dewort is
in need of money for his family so the
two get along pretty well that day at
work they are asked to take fewer breaks
since they took a leave because of a
storm last week the workers are stressed
because of the frequent storms which
curtis deduces is the cause of the
nightmare after work he goes to his
daughter's school for a parent-teacher
meeting on the drive back home another
violent storm hits and causes chaos it
rains motor oil causing curtis to crash
into a tree with his scared daughter
when he wakes up the car is surrounded
by strangers who try to break in to
steal it they break the glass window and
kidnap his daughter in front of his eyes
curtis lets out a loud scream and wakes
up in his bed again it turns out to be
just another one of his realistic dreams
but curtis can no longer dismiss this as
something trivial samantha notices him
breathing heavily and inquires what is
wrong but curtis doesn't tell her
anything trying not to worry her he has
decided to deal with the problem on his
own not by seeking medical help but by
obsessively looking into what his dreams
show him for instance he makes a fence
in their backyard to confine the dog in
case it turns aggressive like it did in
his dreams it relieves him to some
extent but he knows the primary problem
is the storm while trying to find a safe
zone curtis comes across an old storm
shelter in his backyard it has remained
closed for quite some time but he finds
the key in a drawer and opens it the
place is dusty and little but if
renovated it will be the safest place to
be in if something like his dream occurs
in real life at night samantha tries to
talk to curtis about his strange
behavior and is especially mad because
their dog has been left outside however
curtis is glued to the tv too busy to
answer her questions the following
morning he wakes up because of heavy
rainfall upon walking to the living room
he sees hannah looking out the window
and a stranger looking back at her from
their backyard curtis hugs his daughter
as the stranger tries to open the door
when the storm gets worse the entire
house starts moving making curtis fear
for his and his daughter's life just
when he accepts the inevitable he jerks
up from his bed he turns out to be
dreaming for the third time and the
dream was so intense that he has wet
himself in his sleep samantha comes into
the room asking him if he is all right
but curtis is too embarrassed to let her
know what happened he shouts at her to
stay away giving rise to arguments and
tension in the relationship even after
everything that happened curtis doesn't
want to acknowledge that he might be
mentally ill instead of going to a
doctor he picks up a book about mental
health from the library on his way back
he also hoards a trolley full of canned
food to store in the storm shelter that
day samantha organizes a family brunch
and is annoyed when her husband is laid
curtis has also been missing church
service and lagging at his job because
of his obsession with the oil storm at
night samantha waits for him in bed for
hours before finally falling asleep all
this time curtis is busy organizing food
in the storm shelter he hasn't slept
well for the past week and is worried
about his health hence the next day he
finally goes to the doctor with his
concerns he doesn't go into depth about
the dreams and is given some pills to
help him sleep better at the same time
samantha is with her insurance agent who
reveals that their appeal for hannah's
cochlear implant has been approved she
will soon go through surgery and will be
able to hear samantha excitedly returns
home and tells curtis the couple is
overjoyed which establishes a sense of
normalcy in their life again the next
morning goes even better as curtis wakes
up feeling fresh he slept like a baby
thanks to the medicine just when things
start to look good curtis hears a loud
storm again he asks his work buddy to
ward if he hears the noise but the sky
is clear showing no sign of clouds this
time he is definitely not asleep but the
sound continues troubling him the
experience gets so overwhelming that
curtis ends up vomiting and returning
home he then goes to his mother's place
wanting to talk to her about her mental
problems it turns out that she was
diagnosed with paranoid schizophrenia
and he is worried he might have the same
problem the mother tells him all about
her experience and how unknown people
would whisper in her ear all night she
was treated in her 30s and is perfectly
fine right now which makes curtis
believe his condition will also go away
the next day he goes to the bank to take
out a huge loan to repair the storm
shelter the loan puts his daughter's
surgery at risk because the family's
financial condition is not very good but
curtis has set his priorities straight
he genuinely believes that the storm is
about to strike one day or the other and
the shelter will save his family when it
does in the next scene we see him
visiting a therapist to talk about his
problems she breaks through his shell
and makes him talk about the nightmares
for the first time curtis feels a lot
better after talking about his problems
but is annoyed that therapy doesn't
provide an immediate cure on his way
back home a thunderstorm strikes curtis
panics unable to tell if it is real or
if he is dreaming he looks at samantha
in the back seat and sees her sleeping
peacefully which confirms that he is
hallucinating once again the night ends
somehow and curtis continues renovating
the storm shelter dewort brings him
tools from work at his request putting
his own job at risk samantha on the
other hand is terribly worried and angry
at her husband she still doesn't know
about the loan he has taken out but his
obsession with the shelter is ruining
their family at night she forces him to
talk about what is going on curtis still
hides the nightmares from her but tells
her about the loan angering samantha
even more she doesn't tolerate secrets
when it comes to their daughter and is
furious at curtis for putting her
surgery at risk she even thinks of
divorcing him because of the matter
after she calms down a little they
decide to talk the next day curtis takes
double the usual dosage of the sleeping
pills hoping that it will help but as a
result he suffers a stroke late at night
samantha wakes up in distress to witness
her husband vomiting blood and moving
violently she tries calling the
ambulance as he asks her to stop when
help arrives he sends them away claiming
that he is feeling better samantha can
no longer pretend that everything is
fine with their family she demands he
tell her everything making curtis
finally come clean about his nightmares
and the sleeping pills he also reveals
that he had a dream about dwart hurting
him in the storm which triggered the
stroke earlier samantha sympathizes with
him and is ready to do anything to help
him get better the next day curtis asks
his boss to change his shift because he
doesn't want to work with dwart anymore
they make an arrangement that hurts
dewart's schedule and the time he
provides for his family curtis feels bad
about troubling a friend but his mind is
set on removing anything that might be a
threat when the storm arrives after
everything curtis still continues
getting the nightmares as they get
progressively worse one night he sees
his wife standing still in the kitchen
staring at him she seems to have gotten
wet in a storm and is planning to kill
him the next morning he moves when she
tries to touch him making his distrust
clear curtis no longer knows who he can
trust because of this he misses many
days at work prompting his boss to visit
him the man sees the storm shelter and
finds out he has been using equipment
from work supplied by dewart this is the
last straw before he fires curtis from
work this puts the family deep into debt
all because of curtis's obsession a
furious samantha slaps him in the face
and asks him to manage the funds at any
cost they also cancel their annual beach
trip to save money for the surgery in
the following scene the family goes to
church to clear their minds with friends
and family curtis happens to meet dwart
who has been fired from his job because
of curtis he has family and financial
problems of his own and seeing curtis in
a better condition boils his blood dwart
has spread a rumor that curtis is insane
and needs medical attention the tension
between the two causes a physical fight
curtis calls everyone idiots for not
preparing for the oil storm declaring
that only his family will survive it
after the chaos the family returns home
in distress late at night an emergency
alarm is heard that wakes everyone up
the day curtis was worried about has
finally come in the darkness of the
night they rush to the shelter and hide
inside when morning comes curtis hears
the thunder get louder samantha on the
other hand asks him to come back to his
senses and open the door he does is told
to prove her wrong but outside is a
clear day the storm that struck last
night was only a minor one and cleared
up by morning their neighbors are
clearing the little debris left by the
storm which makes curtis finally see
that he has let the paranoia get the
best of him he drowns in the regret of
almost destroying his family over a few
nightmares samantha though is ready to
forgive him and start anew she brings
him to a good psychiatrist where curtis
gets proper treatment for his condition
since the storm shelter is the result of
his obsession he is asked to move away
for a while or go on a vacation to clear
up his mind samantha also thinks it is a
good idea because the family has been
too tense for the past month she
reorganizes their annual trip to the
beach for a week or so in the next scene
we see curtis playing with hannah at the
beach he hasn't had any nightmares in a
long time and it is evident in his mood
as the two play hannah stops giggling
abruptly curtis looks at her and sees
her signing storm on turning around
curtis sees a storm double the size of
the ones he used to dream of it is
coming their way threatening to engulf
the entire city curtis cannot tell if it
is real but seeing samantha's face drop
he registers that she can see it too the
film ends as the family gets ready to
return home before they are caught in
the oil storm
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching